[Music]
hey Lorraine Cink here for the women of
Marvel and I am gonna be talking with
the incredible Mary Livanos from Marvel
Studios the director of production and
development yes hello
what does the director of production and
development do at Marvel Studios for
because I've realized you know a lot of
our friends that are listening to this
are gonna say that's cool what is that
it changes with every with every film
but for Captain Captain Marvel it was my
job to help make sure that creatives
across the board in every department had
all the tools and resources that they
needed in order to tell the story so
let's talk a little bit about Captain
Marv yeah now you talked about
supporting the other sort of all the
different departments different
departments yeah providing key art from
the great khali sea Taconic runs and the
early Captain Marvel runs to working
very closely with the Air Force you guys
worked with two different air force
bases correct yes yes the film shot at
Edwards Air Force Base but the bulk of
our research we conducted at Nellis Air
Force Base with the 57th wing speaking
with every pilot that we could get him
inside their heads and they offered to
fly brie and Anna Bowden up in fighter
jets and I said haha
you're kidding and they were not that
was wild so when you go back and watch
the film now you've probably seen it a
lot more than most of us have what part
like makes you feel the most proud do
you think there are a lot of parts that
make me very proud
I'll take them all the message that
Carol Danvers didn't need fixing mm-hmm
that's what gives me chills when I think
about the movie yeah the thing that
always kind of stuck with me is it
there's a very much a feeling of like
you are enough the way you are and that
realization that she sort of has in a
movie character has problem then by the
end of the movie you need to fix that
problem Carol it was the unexpected
discovery of that that didn't
necessarily need to happen and it was
about self-discovery moments that make
me really really happy when Carol
screams back at the scroll that feels so
Carol I love goose I love you so much oh
and I love the Nick Fury as a cat man
it's just like a great fun detail for
the marketers yeah Mary thank you so
much for talking with us today thank you
so much for having me go pick up Marvel
Studios Captain Marvel now on digital
and on blu-ray on June 11th
[Music]